for weeks the un has been warning
that yemen's dire humanitarian situation
is on the verge of becoming the worst
famine anywhere
on earth in decades today famine
is bearing down on yemen the race is on
if we want to prevent hunger and
starvation from taking millions of lives
to avert humanitarian disaster the
secretary general convened a pledging
conference
to raise almost 4 billion
but while big donors did give money in
most cases they actually reduced their
contributions from a year
earlier in the past the country is
fighting as part of the coalition in
yemen
saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates gave the most
this year their contributions were down
too the head of the world food programme
warned that out of the 385 billion
dollars the un wanted
there was an absolute bare minimum
needed to stop a famine
1.9 billion just to avert famine you can
do the math
that's about 160 million dollars per
month
to have a full refraction but in the end
instead of 1.9
billion they got 1.67 billion
the un's emergency relief coordinator
read out a statement from the secretary
general
showing his frustration the best that
can be said about today
is that it represents a down payment
i thank those who did pledge generously
and i ask others
to consider again what they can do
to help stave off the worst famine the
world has seen
in decades the message from the un to
donor countries is pretty clear
thank you for your money but it's not
enough and we're going to come back to
you
to ask for more otherwise there's going
to be a massive famine in yemen
james bays al jazeera of the united
nations